Molly, you're definitely one
of the best in the world, man.
I get happy when you're refereeing a
fight because I don't know that it's going
to be handled. The, I mean,
I agree with you on virtually every single
time you and I have had a discussion
about what should or shouldn't be
done. Much of a struggle. It is. Right.
Especially clench work. Exactly. The guys
get a guy up against the cage. There's,
they're working for something.
They might stall each other out,
but eventually someone might
break down. Right. I mean,
and this is how a garlic [inaudible]
men off wins fights against elite guys.
This is how Randy coture one, a lot of
fights. It's a legitimate tactic. Yeah.
Cause it doesn't look fun for you.
You know,
like a guy beating a guy up
against the cage is short elbows,
knees to the thighs. You might think
that that's not enough. But that's,
that's uh,
that's a good way to where a dude out
and you keep doing that until eventually
you break them. And especially when you're
someone like Steve Bay or, yeah. Yeah.
I think, I think for me it's helpful as
I do my pre-fight instructions, you know,
so I tell the fighters what I
expect and what to expect from me,
you know what I mean?
So I don't want to,
I want to interfere as little as possible.
Yeah, I know. You know? And so that's,
that's my goal. And so I, you know, I give
them instruction. If I tell him, you know,
hey, work work would I expect
and you know, I expect you
to do something too. I'm,
when I'm looking for big shots
or advance your position.
And then they'll ask me
like, well, how much,
how long will you leave something
stale? I go, well, what is still,
if they're both guys were relaxed,
that still,
but like you're talking about even
up against the fence in a clinch,
especially that's where a lot of
things are really getting decided.
And so we have to really
see that play out. You know,
especially a lot of the
guys are, you know, they're,
they're striking in each other and maybe
in some of the other weight classes,
you know, uh, then they don't
have that one punch all ways. Uh,
some of the guys do,
but not everyone does.
And that's where things are going
to get cited in that clinch.
And if there's a tension,
if there's a tension there,
we need to see where that's gonna
go and let it work itself out.
I'm so glad you said that. That's a
perfect way to say it. That's absolutely.
I hundred percent agree.
And there's,
there's moments where it changes the
course of the fight where it's really
unfortunate. Um, you didn't referee
Camaros, Mana Damien Maia, did you?
I don't think so. Whoever did that
one, we don't even have to pull it up,
but there was a moment in the first round
when Damien Maia got ahold of tomorrow
and was trying to take his back standing
and he had like one hook in a clench
and he was hanging onto him
and the referee decided not
enough was taking place.
They separated them. I'm
like, Oh, you can't do that.
So hard to get ahold of it wasn't me.
Who did that Guy Damien Maia
about to get you back and say,
no, no, that's not going
anywhere. That Sarah went
crazy. You know he has that, um,
that podcast he does what?
Jim Norton and he's like,
you just don't do that until the guy
like he's, he's got a hold of him.
Like he might take his back here
like, yeah, like in, you know,
you saw what he did with lime and
good when he takes your back. Yeah.
In line with goods and pieced.
But when Damien gets a hold,
especially early in the round,
right. And it's fresh and he's,
he's got his back already and then any
other lot of interesting take down from
there too while he's like,
he goes,
goes back and forth with Taf way taking
your back and then when your definitive
take down he starts taking your back and
when you go back then he's back working
on yet. So now he works really, he
works at a real interesting piece there,
you know, it's stunning to
watch him go through. Guys,
like when he went through Rick
story, I was like, Jesus Christ.
Like Rick story's up powerful wrestler.
Yeah.
And when he takes his back and
he gets them in that neck crank,
and he seen the blood squirting out of
his nose and like, Whoa, yeah, this is,
this is a heavy fucking squeeze. This guy
as, and then he did it to Carlos condit.
Um, who else has done to, it's not a
lot of guys. He gets a hold of you.
It's just squeezes the life.
And when he gets on top,
he seems so heavy on Magni when he ran
through Neil magnates like, oh yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. It's just
such high level Jujitsu. You,
he was on top.
He's just just no air to smushes you.